in the fantastical shared world of sea
of thieves the freedom of the pirate
life awaits as players embark on their
own epic multiplayer adventures our
actually titled update 0.1 signals the
star of the sea of thieves technical
alpha thieves and with it some lucky
players from our insider program will
get to experience the thrill of the hunt
as they sail the seas in search of
hidden gold
few things stalk the fire and a pirates
dark heart like buried treasure an
update 0.1 there could be riches hidden
beneath the sands of any island out
there on the open sea but all great
adventures begin with a promise and
that's where our Maps come in when you
embark on a treasure quest in this
update or game you'll have a map to get
you sealing in the right direction in
this case a classic x marks the spot
scale you and your crew will be relying
on this map first to pinpoint the island
then to dig up the treasure making this
a little bit easier as the map table on
your ship this gives you a wider view of
the many islands you can travel to and
your ships possession on the sea by
comparing islands on both maps like some
kind of ingenious pirate detective you
can plot a course and get your treasure
hunt underway ideally at some point
you'll make it to the right island and
face one more test of your cruise
cartographic skills to track down the
Buried stash there won't really be a
giant red X in the sand so you'll have
to use the islands landmarks to find
your way just like both the celebrations
and raiding a seesaw digging for
treasure is much more fun with someone
else and the more of you who help to dig
the faster you'll uncover the bounty but
that's only half the voyage for the real
reward you need to get the chance to
back to an outpost and cache end so
while one pirate hauls the treasure the
others should escort them back to the
ship watching for any sly rivals who
would love to score some treasure the
easy way back on the ship it's up to you
to find a good hiding place for your
precious cargo
there's still a chance that some
enterprising sea dog will sneak on board
and snatch it but don't make it easy for
of course the seas can be treacherous
and your crew will have to work together
to reach a safe haven fending off rival
crews that they get too close
this could be a chance to test your
blunderbuss or pestle by boarding the
ship to engage in a friendly exchange of
ideas if that doesn't go to plan you'll
be taking a trip to the ferry of the
Damned because well you'll be dead but
don't worry too much if you and your
fellow lost souls ask the captain nicely
he may escort you back to the real world
and you'll be back in action so what
happens if your whole ship goes down
well as luck would have it
some friendly mermaids will be on hand
to rescue you and your true because
that's what mermaids do apartment if
after all this you eventually get back
to an outpost with your ill-gotten gains
head to the ship right he'll happily
exchange it for gold
well maybe not happily but she well
exchanged one quest well and truly
smashed
this is just the first glimpse of what's
to come fancy of themes and we look
forward to showing you more as we set
sail through our technical alpha fees
and beyond Cheers
[Music]